[Music]
when i was younger i waited tables like
every
actor and um christian i both actually
worked at the same coffee shop and i
kind of fantasized about going back to
those days and
i've played with the idea of being an
uber driver there's certain jobs that
i'm like please be an uber driver i
think i'm going to 10 years ago maybe i
was in new york with some friends and we
had one of those dinners that had just
kind of petered out and i had sort of
lost interest and i was maybe affected
by certain things that i put in my body
i went over to another table because i
had always fantasized about this and i
just busted it i just started clearing
their plates
and i took them to the kitchen
and the people at the table that i
cleared would had
zero idea that i didn't work there by
the end
the people in the kitchen were no longer
laughing they were like you have another
table to clear like hurry up and bust
that other table
and uh and i i was fully just working
there so uh you should have done like a
dramatic quitting you should have like
dropped yeah a spray of place me like
that's it i can't do this anymore i quit
i'm like stormed out thrown my apron
down
life could be a dream life could be a
dream
you're listening to life for short i am
your busboy justin long life could be a
dream sweetheart
and um speaking of
boys
with me as always is uh my brother
christian who was not there that night
uh nor was he ever a busboy per se oh
but i did work at the coffee shop
i was a boy and i and i bust tables
actually so no i guess i was a bus but
yeah i was a bar back
oh yeah that's that's i don't know what
i'm talking about of course i was a
busboy i just a bus boy for a bar yeah
exactly i was a busboy if barbara were a
bus boy for a bar
your eyebrow just passed up because you
couldn't say that
uh i want everyone to know that
i like that you always point that out oh
you know what i was also talking about
my cool guy face recently and i thought
about you yeah well we'll get to that oh
we talked about it in this yeah okay
uh i i was not there that night but i've
i've heard
james i've heard lore
yeah and it always like just telling it
just now like it's not a story like i
feel like i'm bragging about it but i
haven't talked about it like you're just
like a regular guy
i know it's a little douchey thing to
like it relates and we'll get to why it
relates to our guest today but i don't
often tell it's not really much of a
story it's just like a fun thing for me
to have done i would imagine that people
hearing that story would think of it as
oh he just thought it was a novelty
exactly to do that but i'm here to tell
you guys that
even though i wasn't there i know you
well enough to know that you
genuinely enjoyed doing it and got into
it and liked the interaction with the
customers and it wasn't like oh i'm
going to do some like silly thing to get
attention or something i really believe
that you would maybe want to be an uber
driver now
100 because it'd be fun to meet new
people and yeah everything about your
stories everything about it strikes me
as fun like you're getting also just
getting paid for your time driving
around i like to drive around i like
um i like meeting strangers i also think
it's fair to say you were pretty
unqualified at that point in your life
to be a buster which is why you got in
trouble
right it went from being like a fun lark
for everybody to like uh this okay this
guy's committed to this to the point
where like okay now he's working here
right and he kind of sucks do you know
who else is unqualified
our guest today yeah oh yeah she's so
unqualified that she has a show it's
coming back fortunately for fans of it
like myself called unqualified it's um
one of the first podcasts i was
introduced to and hosted by um my very
very dear friend anna faris
and anna i remember
telling me she was doing this show and i
was one of the first times i even heard
that term podcast podcast what is a
podcast
uh and i just i don't know i don't i'm
trying to remember what i
thought at the time of it it was just it
was a fun excuse to like to hang out
with anna who's my friend who i don't
get to see enough and talking to my
friend for however long that sounds
great and it was i was so taken by it
that
here we are did you meet her doing
waiting no did you know her before that
i met no what am i talking about i met
her the night we both landed we were the
first two actors in that movie uh or
among the first few who landed in new
orleans we got there a day early
and um so i met her
in new orleans and we my first
night with her we went out and just
crawled around the bars of bourbon
street we just explored bourbon street i
don't think either of us neither of us
had been there and uh and so that was my
introduction to anna and it's always
kind of
and it's appropriate i mean
we still have so much fun together uh
but that's how i was introduced to her
found bourbon street going out drinking
hanging out uh just the two of us
strangers like immediately hit it off
you worked with her on mom the show that
she is the very very popular show that
she is the star of uh currently uh you
did an episode of it a number of years
ago and then i just went back to where
where they shot that uh
it's one of my favorite lots it's on
warner brothers right next to the big
bang theory and when i went back they
were i went back there to do actually
honest podcast so i'm a couple weeks ago
a couple days before she did ours and um
it was it's such a fun environment uh
it's it's what i always imagined
hollywood was like you know with gold
hollywood yeah the back lots and you
know people riding around on little
carts and all these characters people
dressed up like these adults smoking but
dressed up as like you know chil
children's characters it's dark yeah i
know i know but like or like you know
roman gladiators and there's an alien
and and they were shooting because they
were shooting space jam too
and and um anna really wanted to see
she's like i heard lebron
lebron is here is lebron the star of it
like the mic is the michael jordan i
think so oh this might be a big scoop
i wasn't i didn't sign anything uh-huh
[Laughter]
so but he was there and she's like
should we go let's go say hi and she did
she did she ended i was like i feel
uncomfortable what would you say to you
know he was in a room with all his
people he knows and is like entourage
and uh she went in there uh and she just
walked right in and i i couldn't bring
myself really yeah i had to go to i know
he'd be great on the show she'd be great
uh but she was great too and uh do you
want to get into it yeah and this one as
you'll hear definitely is more in her
she kind of took control at some point
of this and it does because i don't want
to blame it on her i like it i like the
direction it goes in but this one is
definitely
different than if you're if you have
kids around yeah yeah i would say
definitely um
put some uh move the kids into a panic
room yeah
and prepare yourself for some i would
say spicier
it gets more material yeah hopefully in
a fun way for you guys and if it's not
fun we apologize and uh listen again
please if you didn't like this episode
they'll get queener i promise
uh
and if you do like a little bit more
spice a little more heat to your
to your interviews then uh you you will
do a little sugar in your coffee
you'll definitely like this uh
my um
spicier than usual interview with uh
just
weirdest funniest bests on a ferris life
could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
after i lost my virginity
um yeah i remember thinking my pee
stream was
totally different
i don't know i don't know why after
losing your virginity your urethra would
suddenly have terrible aim that in in a
teenage brain that kind of makes sense
yeah i remember thinking my mom's going
to totally clock this were your parents
really strict with that with me yeah
they because you're peeing on the scene
like no no no no
they were yeah catholic i grew up
catholic did you they want you to wait
till you go um yeah but you know what
they never were explicit about it they
they weren't like
now sex is for marriage so don't we
didn't talk a lot about sex well they
made it very taboo i would say so uh and
we would all kind of tease each other
about girls and stuff i
i remember once being in the car with my
my dad was driving my older brother and
i and i was in the back seat and he was
like halfway through the talk about the
birds and bees before i realized that's
what it was i just remember him saying
yeah what did he say he was very kind of
like clinical about it my dad is a
philosophy professor so he was a real
academic very so he was like when a man
enters a woman's body like what
but when a man enters a woman's butt
yeah i like it i love the idea that it
started out with anal yeah yeah he went
right to he got to the chase
he's the best but we're very different
in that sense i mean it's and i
actually think my dad
isn't prude or like puritanical about
sex at all so okay so how does he
reconcile himself like just the idea of
like philosophy and religion well he is
a medieval philosopher professor so that
was all yeah it's all that's pretty
[ __ ] rap it's cool but it was all
evil what is mine
it's theology it's all like about it's
all religious based it's all christian
based yeah like aquinas so are we
talking about like martin luther stuff
martin luther was yeah i mean that's
later that's more like luther you know
protestantism this is like does he
believe that catholicism was like a form
of like political control or like um
in the sense that back then yeah
um in those medieval days yes he's he
has a great amount of respect for it for
for the the church but also understands
uh that it is like a human system and
humans are flawed and
he's quite
pragmatic about it but back then yeah of
course he recognizes how the the dark
the all the darkness of the catholic and
how do you feel now um
are you are you getting up to the golden
gates uh i would love to i don't know if
i believe in that yes yeah it's hard for
me and especially because i grew up i
know my parents are probably even
listening to this and i i know
hey guys
wendy hi jim and wendy yeah i adore your
son oh he's brilliant what are your
parents names uh jack and karen oh
similar yeah yeah a little story about
jack uh what what what are they like
what do they think so they're they're
atheists but i met them yeah i i'm sure
yeah they're awesome but um but so i
grew up with you know my dad's my
brother's a fourth generation
sociologist i grew up in like within
sort of the academia world
that's right
my thing was that my parents were
atheists but they really wanted me to be
a virgin until i was married
that was why i think my mom had a lot of
like um she grew up pretty poor
and beautiful
she had like you know these [ __ ] up
parents and
um
there were a few traumatic things that
happened and um
yeah yeah but um because my parents
didn't have a
logic behind the idea of me being a
virgin
not that i would have accepted it if it
was religious
religion based necessarily but but it
did make me feel like i it took me until
i was i don't know like 36 to reconcile
my guilt with sexuality like
like i yeah because it was so forbidden
it was so found upon it was like worse
than drugs that's so interesting yeah
did you ever ask them did you ever
confront them about that what is it
about drunkenly once uh-huh and how'd
that go i just cried they didn't they
just like put me to bed and they're like
petting my hair oh but but no when you
were how old
oh that was when i was doing scary movie
one
two the oh boy but uh i i've never been
promiscuous but
which is actually a term that i [ __ ]
hate now that i think about it yeah it's
so happy it's so so
yeah it's so judgmental it is it's not
applied to men actually now
but no
um are you are you a promiscuous voice
no but when no but i still have shape
there's still
remnants of shame and guilt attached to
sex for me even at like in my old age
yeah yeah i it's taken a much different
form now like when i was
yeah i mean i didn't lose my virginity
until i was 18. and i did that feel old
to you
uh
where most of your friends had most your
friends they at least said they did
right and i remember talking about it
like oh you know with the guys in high
school and i remember being somewhat
embarrassed that i couldn't fully
participate and probably even lying at
some point like oh yeah i think i was
more experienced than i was what was
like i want to hear a lot oh i wish i
remember the kids would talk about
like masturbating like jerking off and
i remember having shame about it so i
would say
i remember being in a group of kids
maybe eighth grade ninth grade right
when it was like i was at the height of
yeah
that's all you do oh that's all i
thought about yeah like a stiff breeze
would blow by yeah
i can't imagine what it's like i can't
imagine i was just talking about this
last night that i and i wondered i asked
a female friend of mine uh if if women
experienced this when they were
teenagers because we were talking about
how they hit their sexual peak we hit
our sexual peak much way too early
before we know
what to do with it
i remember the feeling of um having such
intense we will cut this all out uh such
intense like you can't cut this out well
this bonus bump boner talks good
yeah yeah yeah
well we could well okay sorry people
like boners
yeah you indulge in boner talking
okay
such boners that were so
powerful right that they hurt almost and
you just megan i just saw megan's face
from behind the glass yeah but i can't
but right yeah you just have to release
yeah an awesome thing we're gonna cut it
out no don't cut it out no really like
would you leave this in on your shoulder
oh my god yes because i think it's
important because i think that like as
you're saying that it's like this you
know this thing is happening to your
body and it's like [ __ ] there's my shame
maybe that's my shame even as i say it
i'm thinking i'm imagining my parents
listening yeah no jim and wendy are
going to be fine with this they
understood i hope they did it at least
three times
no i think that it's not it's not quite
the same i think that once you kind of
for me at least it was like once you
kind of discover because at least i
didn't
i didn't talk about sex with my friends
but i also wasn't having sex and i
didn't have any friends
that'd be tough
that would be a challenge
you didn't have friends in high school
not really i find that so hard to
believe
i no that's sweet of you to say i had
some but i didn't know how to navigate
especially with women like the like the
female waters i didn't know how to
i i felt like i was too intense i was
too um
i mean that's kind of
self-congratulatory no way to describe
yourself i'm just so intense yeah i'm so
passionate yeah
do you still feel that
you know they say
hollywood and i think it's true
hollywood is just a version of high
school and and being you know being in
this business is a version of just like
a heightened kind of
more public version of high school do
you
do you feel remnants of that of that
high school honor now i think i'm much
more gregarious because
people seem to like
you know people like laugh at the stupid
[ __ ] that i say just because they i have
really blonde hair or whatever but i
would describe it a little bit more like
with fame and success it sort of
intensifies
a part of your personality it sharpens
either something that is that is um
either really negative or positive
that's such a success yeah i know what
you mean like how is it sharpened in a
positive way your personality i'm much
happier i mean i wasn't angry i was so
mad that i was a girl
oh i was so mad so what if you were in a
like a clique like a high school group
what
how would you describe that
is like the c minus d plus i wish i was
like in the f crowd like if you were
great like if you were grading
um
as but and i was uh
you know in the drama club and they
called us the bat cavers
what does that mean really like you were
like a couple kids wore capes and like
there's one kid who had like vampire
fangs okay you know so they were i like
those people i do too but but at that
time
a couple games
that was like from 1991 to 1994. at that
time
fame was not
um something that you overtly saw like
you're right you know you know what i
mean like you would never tell somebody
that you want to be famous oh my god how
embarrassing that would be yeah right
it's hard for me to watch my
hard for me to listen to my voice i'm
making my faces remember when you said
that that you told me that oh didn't you
tell me that oh i see this is my [ __ ]
memory you told me this story and i use
it all the time oh i always credit you
with it okay that is so funny so when i
did mom was it not us
it was it like rob that told rob
mckittrick that told us this who are you
talking about the uh
facebook yeah i made all my faces did it
on my face oh my god i swear to god you
told me i swear to god you told me well
here's the for the listeners here's the
story it's like when i when i did mom
when i did it everyone's gonna love this
story oh my god i was doing mom i was
doing uh on a show and this is the first
season the show so it was six years ago
seven years ago god
life is so short
plug self plug um
i was doing your shot and you it was a
new thing for you to do a multi-camera
show
and you were talking about the um
some of the challenges that you were
facing with this new medium and and a
different style of acting
and
i thought you had told me a story about
it was it was an actor in the like 60s
or 70s one of those sitcom actors who
you told me that you you were shooting
something
and like there was like
some old dude
uh an older actor i have no idea i don't
know 80 in my memory
and uh you were like hey sam like how
was your day and he said did all my
faces
oh my god okay so the
it's the same story really it's the same
story it's just warped yeah totally
warped god i wonder who's right don't
you wish maybe we should have time
machine
who told us this story so in my memory
in my mind it's you who told me who said
and it was in the context of
doing that of being paranoid that you
were just making faces so
to the listeners if this is too insidery
the reason this is such a big fear is
that as an actor you need to inhabit
another person you you become another
person and and hopefully a
three-dimensional [ __ ] is that we're
supposed to do
in theory
uh
but if that's the idea is that like
you're just this other person so to say
to to to to hide behind just making
faces it's sort of like a it cheapens
right
and it's kind of like not what you're
supposed to do but
right you know but i can think of a lot
of actors now who do that yes just make
faces yeah oh well i i a lot of them
just make one face
fascinating yeah there's a lot of like
jaw
yeah
on your end there's jaw on my ends oh as
a woman it's more like
glances and glares i i yes yes i just
realized what you meant by jaw clench
you talk about the clenching the jock
length yeah we've all seen it yep i
caught myself it's like a sweet ass
mirror face
yes yeah like they've studied themselves
yeah and i have i have totally have a
mirror face do you have a mirror um oh
god i hope not you know what my brother
accuses me this is so embarrassing
everybody has a mirror face you can't
not you can't just be like oh like
looking at yourself in the mirror what's
your mirror face it's like it's like
i totally like purse my lips yeah like
you know like it'll like yes like i i
i'm not gonna embarrass i'm not going to
mention her name but she's a
an ex-girlfriend but now a very close
friend and she'll tell me later i'll
tell you and she listens to the show so
i i okay i bet i can guess yeah
she might not be offended by this and we
can cut it out um but she has a face she
does this kind of thing this is kind of
like sultry and i'm i'm pursuing my lips
yeah i try i try yeah that mine's along
those lines well my brother uh and my
friend kier they accused me of having um
every once in a while they'll call me
out if i'm in the if a pretty girl is
around uh they'll they'll accuse me of
having like
a cool guy face oh so embarrassing well
i will but it's something like this it's
like a baldwin brother
you know that like
michael madison like kind of like uh i'm
i'm wounded or like i'm yeah quizzical
like you've got like a lot of [ __ ] going
on james
can't even really make eye contact with
anybody because like yeah but i don't
even realize i'm doing it i know i know
nobody does nobody does it's all that's
the worst part do you think you've
gotten better and i've noticed you've
been so good at redirecting and kind of
focusing the conversation oh do you
think you've gotten better or you're
always good at that i don't love small
talk in any way yeah so like even
interacting with like a stranger at the
airport or whatever i just want to be
like
like oh so you're married wait so wait
what's going on here like i i like you
jump into it yeah which um is not the
best of qualities there were moments
where that uh led to
put you in potentially dangerous times
yes potentially dangerous anna used to
go
and when i when
we were shooting this movie waiting
which we'll talk a lot about if you
haven't seen waiting i apologize uh if
you have seen it i apologize uh if you
like it um you might enjoy this but when
we were doing waiting in new orleans
uh anna would this is where we got to
know each other anna would just kind of
like take off
and um and the next day and she would
end up uh at a pool party with some
teenagers yep that sounds inappropriate
but like not in it it was
well but not in the way you think it
does it is well i don't think maybe i
don't know no we'd be like i don't know
where is this before we had cell phones
but it was like where's anna and she'd
call hours later and she ended up i just
met these people at a at the supermarket
and she would just meet people i told
you about louie and debbie that louie
and debbie knight right [ __ ] france
yes but tell me tell everyone oh it's a
long journey but i went for
this is a good example of that behavior
during that time
um i was engaged yes um to my first
husband and i was really um
i must have i mean hindsight's 20 20
memory sharpens itself i'm but i must
have been um not sure about
the engagement and the impending
marriage
clearly because i viewed
like waiting for me doing that movie
felt like this is like a study abroad i
get to like
just do whatever the [ __ ] i want
um you seemed ready to spread your wings
yeah and there's no better place to do
that than you was yeah yeah yeah so like
night one i remember you were like let's
just trip the light fantastic
we went through it we just kept it going
we like went down bourbon street and
just really did it first i was like this
is going to be a long shoot so anna
myself caitlin doubleday and rob
benedict the four of us were kind of a
little click but in that movie there
were so many actors our age and ryan
reynolds and
yeah
at least for me like i was just
having like i was [ __ ] up yeah i was
exploring like my life i was about to
get married and i think deep down inside
i knew that i that that probably was not
like not the best totally yeah i ended
up calling my high school boyfriend did
i ever tell you about that part
i almost just did a real
almost a real spit
as she was saying i was putting water in
my mouth that was almost there's nothing
better than uh
you didn't tell me that you caught on
that job you called your yeah probably
one of the nights i stayed in you were
not ready to get married i mean i don't
know i mean obviously you just you said
it yourself even at the time i was like
and then he came to visit and
we all kind of and it's weird to see
somebody that you've connected with so
well and we really [ __ ] hit it off
and to see something that you really got
along with not connecting with somebody
they were
committing their lives i don't know how
you
i don't know how you perceived it but i
bet i was kind of scared or like nerves
or on edge you were around him you
behaved a bit differently which which
was really heartbreaking to see because
you're so great you know you're somebody
that i really liked and i was like that
sucks to put a i see that with some
friends you know when they're with
somebody that kind of dampens them a
little bit or or puts like
it limits them yeah it's a shame when
you yes it's true it's true and then and
you you don't seem like that now and i
saw you with your current lover uh and
you seem which is nice to see your lover
even with you know the performer lovers
i've seen you yourself we we can i turn
this back on to you yeah yeah are you
dating what's happening no no current
lover
i have not taken a lover
[Music]
no something
uh well no i mean it's no i'm taking i'm
taking time for me you know
yeah cause i'm 41. what um you are an
anomaly because you're really handsome
oh you're super boy but you do this
thing
that's right you do this thing where you
take because you're like the secret
you're like this underground player this
is your thing with me this is not true
that is so true but you're saying
underground that i see what that implies
to me is that i get more women than i
should no i which i agree with no no i
i do i do think that you respect and
like women like like you do in a
different way than
sleazy guys in hollywood thank you for
saying that i
really try to you do you do you totally
do yes listeners butt
butt ears
here's that caveat oh boy i think it's
disarming to a lot of women in hollywood
okay and so when you dump them
[Music]
is that why you asked me the other day
how many of those relationships ended at
was my doing yeah yeah but i don't think
i think it's
pretty even i don't know maybe skewed
maybe
yeah they just weren't right too i i
look back at those relationships and
it's like it's good i'm glad somebody
made a move because we
weren't meant to be you know you're
completely right life is sure you're
completely right yeah but it's
equality i would never
like oh god that sounds patronizing no
that's what's gonna say that i would
never want you to change about yourself
but that feels like i'm that's nice no
no but i but i love you for this yeah
but i um but i do think that
so many guys have uh an obvious
slickness
to them
that you don't
because you are like you're honest and
you're straightforward
and you're in
and you're interested in people and you
like intimacy you like relationships i
think and then so then when you break up
with somebody they're like
yeah yeah well i i think also i go in
way too fast way too hard and this is
something that this is because you're an
intimate person which is
never yeah it's it's very difficult for
me to be intimate with somebody that i'm
not and this sounds like really [ __ ]
but that i haven't i'm not really
connected to in a deeper way than if you
were to do another profession what would
it be i would i'd love to draw i would i
would probably do something in the uh
drawing i i always want to be a
cartoonist when i was a kid really yeah
yeah i still do really and every year
every you know new year's resolution new
yours comes around will you draw me
something uh this is i like to draw
faces oh you do okay and you know what
you know it's funny you draw alligators
alligators i love old faces and i love
drawing old like overweight faces i
think all men
usually it's hard for me to draw women
huh yeah what about the tits oh tits are
great at drawing tits draw me something
yeah no i'm actually not good at drawing
what tits or hands or body bits you call
them what do you call boobs i don't know
it's all genitalia speak is oh it's
tough wait like it's tough how about how
about [ __ ] dick
um
sorry well well in different contexts
um oh that's right i forgot would you
prefer dick or [ __ ]
um
to reference my own yeah uh or if it's
like somebody if like you're with a
lover i mean it's whatever my lover
would be comfortable with i i guess are
you into maybe this all right i've never
heard anything beyond i've never heard
like your willy oh no no i you're willy
that's a tough one that'd be a tough one
so
right you're right willie yeah it's a
british thing yeah
well which is amazing though about
british culture because they have such a
strong like feminist like
uh the whole idea
yeah yeah so it's like i'm gonna demean
you by calling your [ __ ] up willy you
know we were saying this you you might
enjoy this uh question do you think the
queen wipes her own ass
and historically has the queen
had somebody to do that for not only
does she not have to wipe her own ass
yeah someone bleaches her ass oh you
think the queen
gets her household bleach
why why would she need a bleach dance
way
she like she doesn't have like a
perfectly pink little [ __ ] oh my god
i'm gonna get kicked out of the uk
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and would
shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wonder plus in apple
podcasts or the wandery app
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
did i ever tell you about how i get got
kicked out of new zealand no i didn't
get kicked when you were doing yogi yeah
it sounds so dramatic i didn't get
kicked out but uh i did yogi bear there
and um i was walking
and it was a long shoot there were days
it was like six months right yeah and
there were days most days i only said
yogi
so
you know
yeah sure very fulfilling but i i went
to this concert like the producer
invited me to oh god uh i want to say
it's like queens of the stone age yeah
okay yeah yeah so that's not necessarily
my jam but i left early
um
i had to get to bed sure you need to
yell yogi in the morning
so you've got to do your faces i was
walking back and this should not be an
important detail but i feel
like the societal pressure to make this
a detail that i was wearing jeans
and a t-shirt and a backpack and this
car drives by and they
like these dudes yell out like show us
your tits but in the new zealand accent
shay was your teeth
and
and then and i was like
oh
no i like like it felt a little random
and then another car drove by and said
something like like we want to [ __ ] your
[ __ ] or something like oh my god
it felt like oh my god is up with that
but i could handle it anyway i recounted
this story because it was only what i
had on the george lopez show this very
short-lived george lopez show
and then i got a letter from the
minister of tourism what of new zealand
that i was no longer welcome what in
their country so then it became a whole
thing i had to apologize
well a bunch of feminists new zealand
feminists stood up for me they're like
yeah you're right like
new zealand dudes are dicks and i'm like
i don't have like why what i got i don't
even know
uh they're willies new zealand yeah like
i have no perspective on this and then
oh my god because it became public
knowledge and so then i wrote a letter
to like the new auckland times or
whatever
and i'm saying like
i am very are you like i apologize you
have an amazing country it was so silly
well they felt like you had slandered
the entire country yeah yeah oh my god
but at the very end of that letter that
i wrote to the paper and to um the uh
minister of tourism i said
p.s we have a lot of ding-dongs here in
america as well
you love that it was like word more than
i do ding-dong's a great word yeah
yes yeah it says a lot and they're
degrees of ding-donginess yeah well it
feels like
you're just a [ __ ] ding-dong you're a
[ __ ] ding-dong
you should have said p.s to whoever to
those ding dongs who did yell at me i
will not show you my tits but that's the
thing is that you know i i would have
been willing
i mean no well if they'd approached it
maybe differently
but it's not like that kind of thing
hadn't happened to me
isn't that funny if they just knew that
if they had slowed down if they hadn't
sped away you would have been like okay
right all the time not only new zealand
america oh my god the world where i go
newfoundland
if they're not saying it explicitly i
can see it on their faces they all want
to see my tits
they want to see my ding-dongs
um no anyway so so i had to make up but
i can go back oh they allow they then
you had a nice correspondence yes well
no but a couple years ago i did a air
new zealand uh safety flight studio so
we're good it's water under the bridge
have you ever done an australian accent
before and
you know i have and they always say the
same thing what whenever i attempt your
team to miles trilling accent that's
good i think i don't know
no no
noi you want from becky
what's a becky becky bracky oh bracky
they say
yeah they say bracky
the only way i can do it if like faith
what are you saying i'm from frankie
i've just been so great to have you on
foot now
please tell me
thanks for being early that's him that's
perfect bucky typical egg white on rip
with the
have you been to australia [ __ ] yeah
and there i have this thing where i
i feel
i want to do the accent back as i'm
hearing it i want to do this i can't i
can't do that i'm not great
you are uh such a rare uh performer
you're such an announcer because you
have a very expressive face so do you
you're doing it now you know it's great
i was hamming it up a little okay
i didn't know see and i couldn't i
didn't know i think if i saw a snippet
of your work i would think
whoa i you're you're hamming it up but i
but in the context of your performances
it's grounded you still remain grounded
so i never see it's a very rare
combination i feel the same way about
you yeah that it's like that that
comedic like that thing of like how
earnest we are
but also the idea of i don't know the
honesty
attempt of honesty i guess yeah
do you know what i'm saying like a
comedic it's almost like um
gilda ratner or goldie hawn or lucille
ball these women
kristen wiig these women who are i i
would put you in in that category and
and the thing you all have in common is
[ __ ] them all
oh wow
jesus
okay we gotta spice it up there's a new
sheriff inside davis
you have betty davis eyes that'd be a
good song well thank you
um i wrote it oh
did you no just i'm sorry i don't mean
to deflect no i know it's hard for you
to take compliments don't you think it's
if i did it earlier in this cast you
were paying me a compliment uh and i
know you you yeah you definitely
deflected you're like um it's funny the
faces i
just want to say one more thing about
that about um
we were talking about earlier jaw acting
i remember uh when ben your ex-husband
came to visit and he i don't think my
first husband i always like to do a
martini cigarette gesture yeah
course i live in hollywood california
and then getting the two confused
without my first a second husband
i bore a child
for my loins yes from the second one
jack you bought yourself i'd remember
his name
he's since gone on to be quite a big
deal
that must have been a rock what is that
you go through that publicly you told me
about this a little bit a public divorce
yeah
i wish i had profound thoughts on
i really do i really do because i if i
did i would tell you that
it was incredibly difficult to go
through it publicly but
i think it's just difficult any yeah you
do it it must be difficult without that
well that's why i think about it i mean
i remember you saying some something
like this where we're yeah that's hard
enough on its own and then to have to
this other component where you're like
you're having to answer because people
loved you together and
you were like people liked the idea of
you being a cop and i've been in these
situations where
it takes on a new life but but but
here's the thing i find because i didn't
grow up with social media so i find my
defenses get high
it has like a like a childish reaction i
try to not
absorb i just want to show you something
yeah i just want to show you
glasses
she's reaching into her bag she's
pulling out a clown shoes
a bozo wig
and a cattle prod
oh no okay i need you to read lines oh
no just kidding oh i finally found what
i'm looking for glasses
groucho martin oh they're great they're
new
she's just putting on turtle shell
glasses unconvincing oh really yeah okay
let me put the map back on again uh no
you're showing me glasses you're putting
on your glasses too why did you give me
the screen that script well i don't know
give it back to me do you um no
it transforms your whole face
it's transformed your whole personality
you have a different
you're
making different faces
you have a different personality so you
um
you're mr you're justin long
and um and i'm sorry what is your name
again
my name yes
i'm sorry i called you here for a
meeting i'm karen so do you oh i'm the
sergeant
no it's actually a book that's holding
up this microphone it's it's pure it's
purely funny you don't really read i try
to i don't read as much as i'd like with
sardines of course and and you are an
actor
slightly offensive and
i'm sorry i know you called me in for
this meeting and i'm blanking on
why now um it it is an honor to be in
your company but uh was there something
specific you wanted to talk to me about
i'm just so
bored i'm bored with life oh no mr long
i
i
and you you think i could somehow aid in
your i just
i'm tired of this town
i'm tired of l.a
los angeles i'm tired of feeling
paranoid what are you paranoid of mr
dude everyone reading my emails
well what what are they my ex like
taking all the children
oh no i'm sorry how many
gardeners stealing my bonsai i don't
know like
everything
geez i don't look
and we're just now meeting so i don't
know how much of this i can help you
with i don't know mr long i don't know i
i you know i i would suggest you get
cameras for your bonsai situation you
can get security i have cameras i have
cameras oh
so i have cameras but people can wear
masks
so masked
gardeners how do you know they're the
gardeners oh they might not be they most
certainly are not the gardeners oh okay
i'm sorry i thought you just no it's
probably like amazon people or something
amazon delivery people or amazonians or
it could be uh i don't know the
neighbors everyone's been commenting on
my bonds high oh and they're jealous
jealous neighbors
well mr duchess as much as i'm as happy
as i am to be here i don't know what i
where are these creepy owls um mr duchy
uh just for the listeners i'm is
pointing out everyone is spying on me
well no these owls are just the wondery
these are the ones this is the wonderful
friendly yes well they're all i think
the same
sorry i'm such an [ __ ] no i love this
is what you did we did the other day on
your show i know i'm such an [ __ ]
though wait are you gonna do that every
episode do it uh out of nowhere improv
okay i do
i like it wait can i listen can i tell
you oh before i leave no no okay wait
here are my yeah we have a few more i do
four characters
on my podcast so this is karen karen
um i do
um autumn
from what's from wc
wc w's
this is a red carpet woman oh okay
who are you wearing like uh not
listening really phony yeah
um can i hear her a little bit she has a
better she's about
adam michaela like
adam smith michaela
autumn smith hyphenated a lot of high
school huh
can i hear her a little bit oh yeah yeah
wait hang on okay i also do kayla which
i feel like i've done with you before
maybe
gala is kind she's sort of they're all
awful okay so kayla's a southern lady no
no kayla's not southern oh no she's up
in vancouver oh oh what does she do
there oh she just stalks celebrities at
the gerard room at the sutton place
hotel i'd like to hear kayla if you
don't mind oh yeah sure sure yeah are
you ready yeah okay so setting is okay
um we are at uh
we're at the seventh place hotel uh-huh
in the drive room have i been working
all day you've been working all day okay
gotcha so uh you went back to your room
took a quick shower and then you're like
oh i just gotta like go grab a drink
um hey hey what's up hey
what's up
oh my god wait a minute
are you
wait you are oh my god you're the actor
you're just
justin long right yeah yeah yeah how's
it going what's your name god i'm caleb
thank you it's really nice to meet you
nice to meet you oh my god what are you
doing up here i'm i'm filming something
i'm showing you something
it's a reboot of jaws actually oh yeah
yeah it's fine it was like jaws too well
it would be jaw's fault they don't know
whether they're called just five or
cause i read that one thing that's like
draws a long walk to the bridge
or something that was shooting up here i
don't know if that's that's what it is a
long walk to the bridge well i didn't
know that that must be what they're
calling it yeah that's i think it's got
several working times have an
ex-boyfriend who's like
yeah anyway whatever you have an
ex-boyfriend who wants no no no no oh
nothing but oh my god oh my god
crazy is your ex-boyfriend what is it
like to be
an actor like literally working in
hollywood um
it's a lot of fun i mean this is a
particularly fun job because i it's also
you know it's been a long i was in the
water all day so it's not always
but even that is fun to me yeah that's
cool i like my prune hands so cool that
you have like such a positive attitude
like i love that like some people would
be like oh it was so cold or whatever it
was cold but you know i feel lucky you
didn't get to you seem positive too oh
i'm so i'm like well first of all you
have to know
first of all the one thing you have to
know about me
is that i am a cancer sign and so that
means i am super positive i don't know
much about the different signs that no
cancers they know it sounds negative but
it's actually super positive okay you're
a cancer which means what summer you
were born in august yeah yeah and i'm in
gemini what does that mean oh that means
you're kind of like devilish oh but you
do also have a fun cycle that's funny
you even put a positive spin on devilish
yeah yeah yeah well you know we're all
going someplace at some point oh god i
mean wait that's dude i mean what do you
do always tell me that i'm like i'm
super um
uh intuitive uh-huh so i'm into it okay
does that have to do with the sign of
can't the cancer sign as well kind of
yeah
but no but people always are people say
that to you yeah
well they might it must mean that maybe
you are because you must have said
something in
intuitive about i really like you you
were interesting oh thank you
you are you're interesting sometimes
when you talk to actors up here like at
the bar like they're like oh i don't
want to hang out
but
really interesting well sorry kayla if
you don't mind me saying are you what
are you doing here are you
staying here
at the hotel the sun no no no no woody
uh you're just here for a drink
yeah
you did you
i'm again this might sound where did you
come by yourself you just came to the
bar that's cool
and what do you do
yeah
like
you do
what bunch of things
no
i i
follow my passion
okay that's good that's great what's
your and what is that what's your
passion
i think it's pretty obvious
i it's not
that i'm sorry if if you if it is
obvious i'm not
i i don't i can't quite see it
are you
i knew you weren't that good
you intuited that
are you uh please don't take this the
wrong way this is going to sound really
if it's not true it's going to sound
wildly inappropriate are you a
uh do you work in the
are you an escort of some kind
are you an escort
i will escort you to your room if that's
what you need
no i don't mean like a security
situation but like more of us
in a romantic
capacity
i don't know how to say this i've never
i've been in this position where i've
but you're sort of forcing me
are you intuiting anything about me
right now and the lack of information i
have about you you know what i'm
intuiting what that you're kind of a
shitty actor oh
well that's not fair i i'm having a hard
time understanding you're not
communicating what you what you do or
why you're not well
i thought that i was i thought that i
made my communication very clear from
day one unfortunately you didn't i
really don't
i need more words i need
i need more information words yes you
need
yes what do you do kayla
first of all
okay i will tell you i am an
entrepreneur okay okay okay
what is it that you okay i'm starting my
own makeup line okay
i don't know why you didn't say that 30
seconds ago um i also i have uh like
three stunt people and i'm starting a
union threes what do you mean you have
three stunned people i'm starting a
union how did you get this done what are
they for what do you mean why do you
just don't question me i'm trying to get
to know you you're the one that
approaches you are trying okay fine okay
why do you have three stunned people
kayla because we're trying to start a
union
but how did you come to acquire three
stump it's a different union from the
other stunt union i'm gonna ask you
again are you an escort are you in the
sex business no
this is driving me nuts no i'm not it's
just ugh you understand why i'm asking
that no you're being very cryptic and
corey for no reason maybe
i like chicken wings at the gerard room
okay okay okay so you just came here to
get some chicken wings yeah and maybe
have a nice conversation
i was i didn't mean to be honest you had
a reputation as being like a nice guy oh
so you turned that you're kind of a dick
hey call back full circle
thank you for playing with me
i i don't know if any i'm sorry i don't
know what they [ __ ] you up no life could
be a dream sweetheart
how do you feel about life now do you
feel fulfilled do you feel content no
no
like woke i like who would what kind of
artist would be not thought because i'm
an artist
you fell into a [ __ ]
you don't feel fulfilled doing that just
is the podcast fulfilling in a different
way yes of course what is that way how
would you describe that
controlling of narrative but i don't
think that
would you ever feel fulfilled would you
ever come to a place in your life where
you're like yes
there are days and today is one where i
feel
truly at peace and fulfilled yeah i do
really yeah doing the simplest things i
was i took an uber here
and i and i just was looking at the
window and i was seeing people and i and
i was thinking to myself
this i won't get to do this
for
the
you know that long i won't get to do
this this will come to an end it was
coming out of like appreciation of yeah
that's like the ending of i guess so
it's soaking up the
the the sky and the beauty of life or
the surroundings
i feel genuinely lucky and fulfilled
yeah and sometimes it strikes me to the
point where i become overwhelmed i'm
overwhelmed you remember that scene in
american beauty uh where wes bentley's
looking at the bag and he's like life is
so bad and it's like a cheese and now
it's cheesy but i bet when you first
start
god it was glorious profound right yeah
i i still think it's profound and i
still
and i i catch i catch myself having
moments like that sometimes literally
watching bags fly around i think
it is [ __ ] beautiful and we're like
yeah lucky
work-wise fulfilled
that has changed for me since we did
waiting which was so long ago that back
then it was
if i could get a good movie work with a
good director good actors and and and
you know but i i
i don't chase those things anymore
i don't it'd be nice
do you do you feel unfulfilled in that
in
i don't know why what you like what you
were just talking about reminded me of
um
when i was
17
i went to cabo with my parents and their
my parents friends
and
um
this beautiful mexican
waiter
like
like we had this
like kind of
i don't know we had this little electric
chemistry
and
he um
and
he
came to
our hotel
the next day and he gave me this silver
ring
in a rose
and
it was so
it was i don't know why what whatever
you just said that like
spoke that like yeah i don't know i
gotta tell you for the listeners dear
listeners your whole energy just totally
shifted and you've got this far away
look in your eyes and that's
your whole body is like getting wrapped
up in this memory and it feels like it
was maybe a moment of real true
fulfillment so handsome that's your bag
floating around and yeah yes exactly
yeah i think that's what it was
it was like
that it was like we didn't i didn't know
how we couldn't really communicate but
we had this thing that felt glorious to
me in that moment
isn't that funny but interesting to me
that you now have an understand like a
heightened appreciation for what that
was at the time it was probably really
cool and whatever it was and i think now
i'm thinking back to the time in new
orleans and waiting and the experience
of that
i just
through how many of those we had and and
how i wish
i had the understanding and the
appreciation that i do now for life and
for
living you know i wish i because i look
back at those times and god damn it i
am so grateful for those memories you
know even
yeah yeah
yeah
and i'm grateful for you i i hate using
that term no i know but i but i but i am
like to have a friend that if we've
known each other for this long yeah and
to be able to see after there have been
years i i think years have gone by where
i haven't seen you and
there it's like it was yesterday it's
it's so true yeah it was very very
kismet
[Music]
you don't know the name of the show
i don't know
what would you call the show
uh a ding dong ding dong
ding dong oh i'd prefer that to life is
short oh these are so fast what is your
most commonly used emoji
i i don't ever use them never no
i feel like what yeah i do is i gotta
get rid of that question don't you think
insincere yeah it feels sincere to me i
i don't like it
it feels passive-aggressive and i can't
explain why i know that everyone uses
them but it feels passive-aggressive it
depends on how you're using it i don't
oh my god i got to remember this yeah
yeah what if you say i've always wanted
to go to argentina and then just put the
argentinian flag up there who am i
saying that to you i don't know
karen sarducci no
no no okay no emojis ever nope my
assistant uses uh
emojis apparently oh okay he's the heart
the heart
so you're okay with the heart you don't
like emojis okay don't like emojis you
know what's interesting is this might be
oh wait this is something really quick
the emojis because they are
cheap because they they because you
don't you don't exactly you don't have
investment you don't have to use words
and you have such an expressive face
that you probably think oh they can't
there's no way they can capture the way
a face can
and i was going to say this earlier you
are also one of the few friends i have
who um who will call on the phone that's
become a lost thing
no more i can't i can't not yeah i can't
not but but then but that that means
that that's like once every five months
yeah yeah that's okay i'll take it um if
you could be a professional athlete what
sport would you play and why oh
it's a tough one do you watch sports yes
yeah but okay i want a singular like
maybe it goes back to i don't know i
would like to i
soccer uh no because i don't want to be
a part of a team i want to be so like
interesting yeah i i um
i i'm gonna go with like
kids sailing the sport okay yeah yeah
well you were brought up to the second
time you brought sam yeah did you say
you grew up in washington state did you
say all there yes i did no i didn't well
i did a little bit okay
uh if you there's so many things it's
too short life is too short if you could
have one snack food for the rest of your
life what would it be
you're stoned let's say you're stoned
for arguments
what was your answer i love pizza
goldfish
i could eat bags of them peppers form
chessmen are you being sponsored by no i
wish
i would wish who makes them let's get
used to pepper's farm pepperidge
pepperoni listening i don't think they
needed this it would be here's my
brother and i have this thing where this
would this would be the best commercial
just if i do say so myself give me or
somebody who likes goldfish as much as i
do a bag of goldfish and just put the
camera on and watch a person enjoy it
watch
in this case me enjoy it it sounds very
good
is it like a childhood like they're just
so satisfying to me they tick so many
boxes of taste like um they're just so
satisfying i don't know i love doritos
i love doritos but we get really snacky
when you
you know i don't smoke weed you don't no
i get too paranoid oh right i i listen i
drink
because a few times i i know you will
just french exit oh [ __ ] yeah yeah i i
can't like anyway by the way we talked
about a lot of things that i i wish we
could talk about again but we talked
about them on your podcast so i want to
just tell everyone to listen to that um
thank you
probably you give me a shout out yeah
it's just they call it these days shout
out it's podcasting term guys
from one of the ogs what's what's the
new show called
mom
airs on cbs right everyone knows that i
know um no still unqualified still like
okay good i'm qualified uh your favorite
movie of all time
i really love about a boy oh that's sick
yeah i love that soundtrack yeah if you
could have dinner with three but i love
you too what three people dead or alive
whom you've never met all right never
mind who's your favorite muppet
animal great you are you have a real you
i can see that
i've seen the animal come out and it's
really fun uh if you could have one
superpower what would it be
this was misleading when i said these
are quick i know i know i'm sorry they
are and you're very introspective yeah
because normally i would say flying but
is there a world where i could also
become some kind of human submarine sure
where i could dive like aquaman
aqua woman [ __ ] aqua lady i guess they
did it
aqua gal so we don't have imagination
you can do anything i ask this okay all
the time what is greater our imagination
as humans
or reality
definitely our imagination oh my god
definitely nope [ __ ] no oh really yeah
this would be great or what would it
mean greater maybe
because
like the best we can come up with is
like unicorn a horse with a horn or like
a like
octopus like all these things have
already been developed that's true there
are there's some crazy [ __ ] that is
can't
we that's true our lack of imagination
is what limits us that's a really good
thank you very much i i appreciate that
that is a really good point it's true i
mean if we if we had never seen animals
right imagine
imagining some of those animals i would
never be able to right
all of our
yeah all of our artistic
inspiration comes from things that we've
already seen yeah a pelican i'd never be
able to conjure up a pelican if i had no
frame of reference giant clam
well maybe that would be
oh boy you'd have an easier time yeah
okay and then we're back and we're back
that was great that's for you yeah
and your love of vagina talk this was
one of the grossest ones fur burger do
you remember that no what's a fur burger
think about it okay so it's a [ __ ]
covered in fur hair
okay so or hair i almost i'm doing a kid
show i'm hosting a kid show and i swear
to god i almost made a merkin joke
on the show the other day i'm so glad i
didn't
have you american you've been for an
american yeah vodamark and it's
different for a lady you have to put a
tampon it's it's
i didn't know that yeah see we we have
to work things called [ __ ] socks which
is really uncomfortable it's a it's a
flesh colored and it's always wait are
you are you uncomfortable
doing it or do you sort of kind of get
off on it no because here here's why
because it's first of all it's also very
unflattering because it's a tiny piece
of material to the point where you think
not to toot my own horn but i don't
think i'm going to fit in that you know
and then it and then it kind of sucks
all your stuff to get it's made of such
a material that it kind of like sucks
all your stuff together so it's a very
unflattering little ball a little ball
of
junk
of male junk
uh
if you could be one age for the rest of
your life physically what would it be 83
it's funny you have a lot of things in
common with jesse eisenberg he said 85 i
think um really yeah yeah what why
because you feel sometimes at heart like
an older i don't really mean it oh it's
just that i don't want to be hung up on
yeah age because it's like the trains
left the station and that could be
so it's like well what how we can't like
you could fight so much it's true then
you can't fight it's a potentially
loaded into presence with some apple
juice
like a kid
um almost done if you could be a
non-human animal what would it be
i think that everyone goes towards the
carnivore right like
like a tiger lion or eagle or whatever
mighty that predator but do we value
longevity over
um
like do i pick
coral a clam giant clam back to the clam
like it just depends like how
interesting is my life
coral reef well beautiful i mean
you get did i get to just live for like
500 years
and just see [ __ ] go by
hey i said the other day i said today
how fulfilling that was to just watch
life go by i might like that i might
like to be a coral or a giant clam for
hundreds of years that's it oh beetles
or stones
oh
that is cruel
why would you do that do you do this to
every guest yeah they don't usually
struggle with it as much as
you are sorry and you gotta go
all right never mind stones maybe i but
no one
what if i become friends someday with
paul mccartney and
he's resentful because he listens to
your podcast he probably does and i
couldn't help but hear that thing you
said about nice
you know it's been bothering me the
whole time we've time timelessly urinate
so badly okay let's go okay like four
more questions what a great way to end
it no that's it i was going to say how
badly do you have hearing aids
uh they're the beatles it's easy for me
[ __ ] you
what a great
note to end on
and [ __ ] you and jim and wendy i love
you i love your son yeah okay all right
you gotta go pee and uh
watch mom listen to unqualified hey
everyone
um please listen to uh justin long's
um say it ain't so podcast
so i like that i also like that you
plugged a podcast that presumably people
have just heard
[Music]
wow that really happened it sure did
how many people did we lose uh i i mean
the one real problem with it is i just
wish you guys had talked about genitals
more
it just it was it was almost enough
but it never for me for me personally it
never quite got there oh really you
could you would have i wonder if it
broke some podcasting record probably
because podcasts haven't been around for
that long so i'm not i hope that's not
here i'm sure they're podcasts that talk
about genitals a lot more aren't there
like i'm sure there are like genital
themed podcasts there's 650 000 podcasts
that's true oh my god what er what
genital talking arrogance i just
displayed
yeah
i was pretty
listening to it it's funny like being in
it when i was doing it it felt so
natural and easy and fun i mean she's
just i want to my i hope that part is
clear i mean that it's
favorites i i wasn't there so i just
listened back and
i was like what the [ __ ] is this
it's like
she's so uh she's just so random and she
says things out of the blue and that's
why it's hard to have a um like a
sustained linear conversation because
she just says the most random [ __ ] that
that and and you're good at going with
the flow she was like that when we were
hanging out in new orleans when we were
we had this little we talked about our
little group called this we called
ourselves the cc's because we would go i
don't think we mentioned this we
consistently go to the same bar called
the cajun cabin for whatever reason we
go there all the time and one time donna
we both
jumped into this jug band where they
have um you know they play like the
what's that washboard so and they were
like oh yeah come on into our band we
played in this
jug band with the washboards and
somebody played the spoons and they were
really into like having other people
participate and then a bunch of bar
patrons started participating anyway um
we saw since then we called ourselves
the cc's and
and that night or a couple nights later
on i didn't know where we would just
broke out into this british accent like
an old queen and she was like i declare
you the president of the cc's and she's
just like playful like weirdly playful
that's why she would befriend like
tweens that's a good name for her
autobiography weirdly playful yeah it's
funny that you say that about all your
bar experience because listening to it
this specifically felt like i'm at a bar
with you guys like you guys like you
know take too much adderall yeah
it was like a very barre conversation
yeah it's kind of random and all over
the place but fun
yeah it was really fun and like rip
ripple ribald
i've never known how to say that i know
how to spell it r-i-b-a-l-d
rippled yeah
ribbled it's like body it is ripples
there must be a better one i haven't
thought of that word in a long time
hopefully somebody will write me a
shaming letter about it a canadian
christina teo right back or uh brittany
t
uh it was very hard still is hard for me
to believe that she didn't have many
friends in high school she talks about
that i know because it seems like
she would be so easy to be friends with
i mean she not only is she very outgoing
the little little i know her but she's
also
approachable but that may be like you
know how i mean we talk about this a lot
the memory how memory is is
tricky and you create different memories
but you know what this actually relates
to that we have obviously that moment
where i cannot remember that story i did
all my faces which i think is a very
important story for anna yeah i did my
faces story it's i've heard you
tell that story to me before about her
so at least in your memory it's been
cemented as oh she did say this and in
hers it seems like it was cemented that
i had said weird yeah so strange i
wonder don't you wish there's a way to
get the truth out of yes yeah i will say
she has in my opinion a great podcast
voice she's a great voice because i i
noticed that it's like
it's sort of smoky and sexy
but also
kind of cute and accessible and open
it's weird it's a weird combination of
like it's kind of
i can't do it i'm not gonna do it please
don't especially while you're looking at
me
gross but you know what i mean it's like
it's like i know sexy but also kind of
young and and and playful playful
it's all these like yeah it's a really
good voice
for all her random like
tangents and like
like improvs out of nowhere she's also
very she's very smart and she's very
good at like redirecting and
and and if she does it in like
a traditionally
interview responsible way she's able to
redirect it back on track wait yeah
here's what you were saying she did it
to me a couple times
she's really very smart it's almost like
that quote-unquote random stuff isn't as
random as we think it is i think it's
more deliberate i think it's more like
this would be fenner i think she finds
it entertaining which i do too you
talked about your cool guy face uh
i can't believe i said that and well
here's the here's the worst part is that
you first of all you do do this you have
this sort of
like handsome squinty face when you're
trying to present your your best luke
in public that's so embarrassing but
here's the most embarrassing part is
that you compare it to james dean i know
i know i wish you were gonna new you
which for all you listeners it does not
look like james dean
hold on hold on i obviously don't think
my facial structure
is in any way comparable
here's the only way i meant it is that
my friend max mengele calls it um
laserface
have you ever heard max say
where they're like they're they're
squinting and they're so kind of like
focused on something but uh in like a
far-off place they're like looking in
the distance cool guys all really happy
i mean all handsome guys have that
potential but you do the thing where you
like can clench you and i could see your
you like manipulating your jaw so when i
say james dean it's only like i'm
aspiring that's the like platonic form
yes like it is cool it is the platonic
forum yeah it's embarrassing i can't
believe it uh she is so i i was so
struck by how honest she is and how
candid about things that are even
potentially embarrassing honest
she's she's just such an open book and
and i think that
fearlessness really creates a fertile
podcast environment you know it does and
she does that on the show she you know
she i mean sometimes sometimes too
honest you know i would say
but it's still i think it's good to err
on the side of
too honest than not yeah in a podcast i
just can't do that i had a heart i'm
just talking about sexual stuff i'm
still i don't know if it's catholic
hang-ups or i don't want like you
getting
uh
boners in like in an easy way when
you're 14 years old
i think is
funny enough and not gross enough to
talk
i think so i don't know of course
they're my boners so i'm more kind of
like sensitive to talking about them
[Laughter]
uh it's also a funny word boner can you
it's believed that there was a character
on net network tv i know boner stabone
yeah
yeah also the word the owner is used as
like oh you made him boop
that's right like you made a real boner
yeah well that was a boner move for a
bun bonehead is different you guys talk
about the queen getting her [ __ ]
bleached and i if you or anyone
listening is
curious about my opinion about that i
would say
i think anna is wrong i don't think the
queen gets her [ __ ] bleached because
it would be one thing if the queen had
to look at her [ __ ] and she'd want
everything to be you know perfect and
sparkling
but
why would the queen care about that i
thought the same thing i and she i think
sometimes anna takes a very concrete
position on something that she hasn't
totally thought through
but then here's what i love about it she
thinks through it and and you can kind
of swear but we didn't have time to like
i know get into the weeds and the queens
that bleaching or [ __ ] you guys also
both deflect compliments in a very
similar way like you both don't like to
take compliments i'd rather not hear
this
not a compliment i could have done
without the improv scenes yeah also
i mean at first it was like oh that's
weird and random but then at a certain
point it's like oh god and i wonder if
she's doing this on her show because she
doesn't get to play that on mom it's
like her wanting to do that because
that's what she's so yeah she must miss
doing that right part of her i think
that's where a lot of that comes from
that's interesting of course you
bookended the interview with more
general chat uh it was it started and
finished with some genital talk and uh i
regret saying one do you know which one
i regret yeah uh fur burger oh no not
that there was something else you said
that was gross oh really that yeah
that's just the one that jumped out to
me berber is gross gross uh all right
let us uh let us read a letter like we
do after all let's redirect let's pivot
um okay this is from allison r
hello
i've recently started listening to your
podcast and absolutely love it we should
cut out the like
why who cares it's good to hear that
people like okay but she loves it that's
not so nice allison thank you your
stories are always entertaining
it's from allison even when you are
plugging your ads anyway i'm emailing
you guys to tell you a story of my
senior year of high school i graduated
high school in 2006 during that year i
was waiting for any acceptance letter to
any of the colleges in which i had
applied well i had not gotten any
acceptance letters yet i had a few
rejections so i was getting a little
discouraged one day i received a phone
call from my dad who was ecstatic i had
received an acceptance envelope from the
south harmon institute of technology i
told him i didn't apply there i've never
even heard of that school i came home
and had to break it to him that this was
advertising for a new justin long movie
that sucks
oh my god this memory always makes me
look back and laugh
i ended up going to indiana university
so all was not lost anyway whoever did
your marketing for that movie did a
great job well thank you i would i would
argue that's
maybe not but maybe like too great a job
like that's
that's really funny the poor her poor
dad must he was ecstatic and it was like
he must hate me he must be like what he
must hate you yeah yeah what a shitty
fake out
south harmon institute of technology i i
there a lot of people still come up to
me they'll say i'm a [ __ ] because
that was the acronym you know what's
funny about that is i knew you're going
to say this
you were you got like a twinkle in your
eye
so christian
was actually in that movie and he so
that so the south harmon institute of
technology for those of you who haven't
seen it i've created this fake school i
played this kid who didn't get into
college and the acronym the letters were
it's s-h-i-t south harmony
um so [ __ ] so and we were and the people
who went to that school were we were
called [ __ ] and um our mascot was
was a [ __ ] sandwich christian's just
waiting he's just
guessing guess who got their hands on
that roll
[Laughter]
so
uh christian was playing
he was all set he inked a deal to play
this [ __ ] sandwich
so one day uh
he was in i walked into the makeup the
hair makeup trailer and it was so fun
it was so funny to see and i i see him
and getting his makeup done and they're
just painting his face
brown which i didn't occur to me at the
time
how kind of problematic that is yeah
but not for the reasons that it's but he
was getting it painted brown so that he
could be
in this [ __ ] sandwich from this big foam
sandwich and i
all i had to do in the movie i had to
walk by
justin's character and say hi to him and
that's it i remember hi b my i played a
guy named bartleby they let me be and i
i remember being an involved shot for
that especially for that size of a move
it was it was like a um steady cam which
means like a guy had to carry this big
heavy camera that's when cameras were
heavier back then and he had to walk it
was
he was following me walking into this
campus that we had set up this like
school that we had set up so it was it's
called a
steadicam tracking shot so they were
following me and was kind of involved
and and christian was like a
moving piece of that where he had he'd
have to like hit a mark and go
but the point is we did we had to do it
a lot and it was outside oh my god i
forgot to remember that so hot and
christian is i don't know if we've
talked about yeah christian sweats a lot
like everyone knows ha ha
but also christian was wearing a big
foam [ __ ] sandwich
and it was like the middle of august and
his brown face makeup was sweating off
and there was like there were two people
with like little fans who kept following
me around and like like two pas who kept
not fans are not like aficionados
not fanatics
yeah they were fun and which isn't so
embarrassing i hate that happened to me
the other day where like
you know if you're shooting something
outside they it's their
you know you have to stay you can't beat
your makeup and it's their job to touch
you up yeah and you feel terrible it's
terrible with the holding they're
holding a face so it's a pretty brutal
day but uh
once every four months i get like a 26
residual check for that movie so haha
yeah who got the last laugh
we got to find a picture of that it's so
funny um but that was uh anyway so thank
you allison r and i'm sorry to mr r
well anyway uh that was the show thanks
for listening yeah
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
if you like us um on the go on the
internet and give us a five star rating
even if you think it should be a four
star rating just give it five yeah who
cares even if you think it should be
three it's free love you short is hosted
by me justin long it's produced by
former [ __ ] sandwich christian long and
megan monaco our senior producers
michelle mishlans and our audio engineer
is marcelino vilpando what a great name
executive produced by marshall louis
also fun to say and hernan lopez really
fun to say yeah for wondering
[Music]
i forgot about these
chess men
that
when i was a kid i used to think this
too
it was very difficult for me to not eat
an entire bag oh really
yeah i could keep do you like them
yeah and like when i
there there was a time i think when i
first was able to like buy my own things
you know like in high school when you
can start like
like [ __ ] i can have my own
girl scout cookie like old box of them
and just like pay for because i made
money at the cup whatever
i remember like buying bags of these
yeah and just being like holy [ __ ] i can
do this i love them that much
it's they're difficult
like they're delicious i mean i i get it
that flavor never
cooks i know i know you love butter
cookies
i like butter cookies i've never
these are i don't know what makes them
different and these have that sweet
outer layer oh man
i used to eat around the design i i
these yeah yeah
yeah
that must be difficult to do yeah but
it's part of the fun i would eat the sex
this side has glaze too
the whole rim
oh that's right
well you really know oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'm like the gary kasparov of uh
yeah no no chess man cookies
oh you mean like people who play chess
no no
the cook
you know pepper's farm
they're so [ __ ] good i i
i could do a commercial for these
if you just fed me some of them it would
that be a good commercial just feeding
somebody's the actual product and
watching them react
like a natural reaction
just like
you can't do too many takes
just give them something really great
and like just react the way you would
react naturally
i guess it's
you